yet another teacher has fired a gun in
school this time there were injuries in
fact three students injured and this
relates to sort of a follow-up story
last week I told you that in Georgia a
teacher barricaded himself inside of a
classroom and fired his gun when the
school principal was approaching the
classroom and fortunately didn't hit
anybody
teacher eventually arrested without
further incident and we have another one
of these stories this one relates to a
teacher named Dennis Alexander in
Meredith California who fired a pistol
inside of class while reportedly either
lecturing about public safety or
teaching students how to disarm someone
with a gun which raises more questions
than it answers actually three students
were injured nobody died the gun was
pointing at the ceiling
when the teacher fired it bullet
fragments bounced off the ceiling and
hit a student in the neck students going
to be okay and then two other students
were hit not by bullet fragments but by
debris caused by the firing of the gun
and those are also minor injuries so
this one is already getting super
complex right first question is is the
teacher allowed to have a gun on school
grounds and the answer is unclear
because teachers aren't supposed to be
armed but this teacher happens to also
be a reserve police officer force and
city police in California and there are
exceptions to the no guns on school
campus on school property rules for law
enforcement but what about part-time law
enforcement does it apply if you are
sometimes part-time law enforcement but
you're there as a teacher and not as a
cop I guess we're going to see but until
they figure out whether or not he's
allowed to have a gun he's on
administrative leave but I want to get
to really what the other question is
here I've talked about how really an
accidental shooting is a negligent
discharge of a firearm so he's obviously
going to be charged right with negligent
discharge of a firearm well maybe not
the problem is how the California
negligent discharge law is written this
is Penal Code to 46.3 and it says under
California Penal Code you commit the
crime of
discharge of a firearm if you willfully
discharged a firearm in a grossly
negligent manner which could result in
someone's injury or death accidental
shootings by definition are not willful
and thus I am not expecting there to be
charges here and whether or not there
are charges whether or not the law was
broken here isn't it very clear that
arming teachers is a terrible idea I
mean this was a reserve police officer
and teacher who injured three students
by accidentally firing his gun and
people are talking about arming teachers
and the other really strange thing that
I alluded to earlier is that most of the
reports are saying the question was why
did the guy have a have a firearm anyway
most of the reports say he was in the
middle of teaching Public Safety help
seating Public Safety in the class but
there's a couple of reports that say he
was teaching students how to disarm a
gunman which number one why is that
something that you you would be teaching
in school to begin with and number two
why do you need to do that with a loaded
gun
like even if we say okay we're gonna put
aside the analysis of why this is
something the guy was teaching why would
you be teaching that with a loaded gun
how is it even possible that this is
going on I don't really understand it
but there's certainly more than we've
learned so far here and obviously
there's only one solution here which is
we have to get rid of schools altogether
no I'm sorry that that's that's stupid
we need to arm the students to defend
themselves from the teachers but keep
the school yes I mean he wasn't cautious
enough to know that the gun was loaded
maybe there was one in the chamber yeah
at least he was cautious enough not to
point the gun at someone or at the wall
across from him I guess because this
could have been a lot worse for all we
know at some point he did point the gun
at someone or at the wall across the way
and eventually by sheer luck or odds I
don't know what you want to call it it
discharged when it was pointed up at the
ceiling but I mean just think about this
was a discharge into the ceiling and
three students were injured fortunately
only fortunately none of them super
seriously and only one of them even had
what we would consider more than minor
injuries but that's an accidental gun
shot at the ceiling
imagine the degree of chaos that could
be wreaked with these guns in schools
you know the if the the firearm is
pointed almost anywhere but the ceiling
and he perhaps was teaching the students
how to disarm a gunman yeah so I'd
imagine that demonstration had him
moving around I guess jockeying and
jumping and the gun would be pointing in
a whole bunch of different directions
I can't even no it's good that he
pointed at the ceiling at least at the
end yeah congratulations you didn't
actually shoot anyone directly only
bullet fragments hit a kid please let's
just move away from this idea of arming
teachers today's program is sponsored in
part by Celsius a new global
peer-to-peer financial platform that
connects holders of cryptocurrency
assets with borrowers and it will also
allow crypto holders to earn interest on
their assets in the form of coins or to
get US dollar loans against their crypto
assets this is a model for a project
with a ton of demand for what Celsius
will do they just added to their team
Sayid Fazli the former CTO of Bloomberg
and the team at Celsius says that
they're doing this to bring a new wave
of financial products to the market
designed to always do what's in the best
interests of its members instead of
trying to make as much profit as
possible like the usual big players in
the financial world that we talk about
all the time their token will be used
for its actual purpose virtually from
the outset and you can learn more at
celcius dot network slash crowd sale in
the US it's open only to accredited
investors and you can sign up at Celsius
dot Network slash crowd sale this is not
financial advice please do your own
research and due diligence before making
any financial decision